retenu par le président du Sénat sur le
fondement des propositions des groupes
politiques
le Sénat souhaite rappeler la mémoire de
Massa Amini décédé le 16 septembre
dernier en Iran après avoir été arrêté
pour une mèche de cheveux qui dépassait
de son voile et celle de adis Najafi
exécuté par la police parce qu'elle
réclamait sa liberté en tant que femme
et iranienne
nous souhaitons lors de ce débat rendre
hommage à l'ensemble des victimes de la
répression du puissant mouvement de
contestation en Iran et à toutes ces
femmes et ces hommes qui revendiquent
aujourd'hui leur liberté et nous nous
saluons unanimement le courage
je vous rappelle que dans ce débat le
gouvernement à la possibilité la faculté
pardon s'il le juge nécessaire de
prendre la parole immédiatement après
chaque orateur
pour une durée de 2 minutes l'orateur
disposera alors d'un droit de répartie
d'une minute le temps de réponse du
gouvernement à l'issue du débat et
limité à 5 minutes madame la ministre
vous pourrez donc si vous le souhaitez
répondre après chaque orateur une fois
que celui-ci aura exprimer son
expression
dans le débat la parole est à Madame
Annick billon
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le 16 septembre
dernier la mort de Macha Amini
âgé seulement de 22 ans après son
arrestation par la police des mœurs pour
avoir porté une tenue non appropriée
nous approfondément choqué depuis l'Iran
connaît une contestation populaire d'une
ampleur inédite des femmes des hommes la
jeunesse iranienne manifeste chaque jour
dans les villes d'Iran pour exprimer
leurs colères le mouvement de
contestation entre maintenant dans sa
troisième semaine et ne faiblit pas tout
comme la répression sanglante organisée
par le pouvoir en place les dernières
nouvelles qui parviennent à sortir du
pays malgré les coupures internet
organisées par le gouvernement font état
d'une centaine de morts et de plus d'un
millier d'arrestations arbitraire la
police n'hésite plus à entrer dans les
universités pour réprimer les étudiants
soupçonnés d'apporter leur soutien
à la lutte pour le droit des femmes la
persécution des femmes en Iran perdure
depuis de nombreuses années et si l'on a
pu espérer quelques améliorations de
leur statut sous Hassan Juani l'élection
du président et Brahim Raissi a mis un
terme aux espoirs de progrès en faveur
du droit des femmes dans son dernier
rapport annuel sur l'Iran Amnesty
internationale est sans concession la
discrimination envers les femmes sont
nombreuses mariage divorce emploi
succession ou encore accès aux fonctions
pu politiques les inégalités perdurent
les droits des femmes et des filles sont
bafouées par le régime iranien par
exemple l'âge légal du mariage est
toujours fixé à 13 ans et les pères
peuvent obtenir des autorisations pour
marier leurs filles à un âge encore plus
jeune
le port du voile imposé par la loi est
synonyme de harcèlement quotidien
d'invisibilité des femmes de détention
arbitraire date de torture et d'autres
mauvais traitements de la part des
Gardiens de la Révolution ces
contestation qui se sont levées à la
mort de Macha Amini ne reflète pas
seulement le recul du droit des femmes
mais dénonce tout un régime et ses abus
femme vit liberté nous devons faire
notre ce magnifique slogan des
manifestants et manifestantes qui ont le
courage de défier le pouvoir en place
pour mettre fin aux terribles
discriminations dans son victime les
femmes iraniennes la communauté
internationale si elle est attachée à la
défense des droits des femmes doit
envoyer un signal fort et unanime pour
soutenir cette contestation historique
madame la ministre quelles actions en
faveur de la contestation populaire
iranienne le gouvernement quand il
mettre en place ce sujet fera-t-il
l'objet d'échange lors de la réunion
informelle des chefs d'État de l'Union
des sanctions semblent être en
discussion qu'en est-il
et pour conclure que penser de
l'élection de l'Iran à la Commission de
la condition de la femme de l'ONU en
2021 alors que la persécution des femmes
en niant y est systématique l'Iran
a-t-elle vraiment sa place dans cet
instant international dont le but est la
promotion de l'égalité des sexes et
l'autonomisation des femmes faisons
notre ce slogan femme vie liberté
merci chers
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues en Iran depuis la mort
de Marsa mini interpellé il y a trois
semaines par la police des mœurs parce
qu'une mèche dépassée de son foulard là
contestation ne retombe pas elle touche
l'ensemble du pays la répression est
féroce le nombre des morts et des
personnes arrêtées montent chaque jour
et les revendications dépassent la seule
question du port du voile ce sont
désormais le guide suprême et le régime
qui sont remis en question de son côté
que fait la France notre président se
drop dans un silence
opportuniste on ne touche pas trop à
l'Iran
utile en cette période de guerre à l'est
avec le probable retour sur le marché
international de ce grand vendeur de
pétrole que l'Iran lors de son entretien
à New York avec le dirigeant ultra
conservateur iranien et Brahim raïti on
mange de l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU
le président de la République a juste
demandé une enquête transparente sur la
mort de Marsa Amini les échanges se
concentrant sur le dossier nucléaire
iranien
actuellement les manifestants femmes et
hommes s'organisent en partie ce qui est
à la fois leur force et leur faiblesses
cette spontanéité fait que des cinéastes
des athlètes des musiciens des artistes
expriment leur solidarité le pouvoir
annonce qu'il s'en prendra au célébrités
qui ont soufflé sur les braises le
réalisateur Ashgar Farhadi deux fois
oscarisé lui a invité tous les artistes
cinéastes intellectuels militants des
droits civiques du monde entier a
exprimer leur solidarité et l'artiste
franco-iranienne Marjane Satrapi d'un
système il faut envoyer un signal fort
en France une cinquantaine de
personnalités d'artistes femmes ont déjà
hier diffusé une vidéo où elle se coupe
une mèche de cheveux en soutien aux
femmes iraniennes j'appelle tout le
milieu artistique et les personnalités à
rejoindre largement cette mobilisation
quant à nous les politiques au-delà des
protestations d'usage ne devons nous pas
faire pression avec vigueur et
conviction sur l'exécutif pour qu'ils
sortent de sa freelosité
mobilisons-nous évitons surtout
d'instrumentaliser la lutte des
iraniennes pour régler nos différents
intérieurs sur la question du voile en
France l'enjeu de nos engagements est
clair la liberté et les droits humains
je regrette qu'il n'y ait pas assez de
monde
aujourd'hui où il est nécessaire de se
mettre d'accord et faire des actes
symboliques pour montrer notre soutien
aux iraniennes et aux Iraniens merci
merci cher collègue
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant à Madame
Ghislaine Pantel pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues
dans un premier temps au nom du groupe
le Rassemblement démocratique et social
européenne nous tenions à remercier les
organisatrices et organisateurs de ce
débat d'actualité au combien fondamental
pour quiconque se réclame de l'humanisme
à plus ou moins 5 heures d'avion de
Paris la mort de la jeune Massa à mini à
22 ans le 16 septembre dernier a
déclenché un grand mouvement de
libération des femmes et de
contestations contre le régime
autoritaire de la République islamique
d'Iran la disparition de la jeune fille
d'origine kurde et le fruit d'une
arrestation violente de la police locale
des mœurs ayant pour motif un port de
vêtements inapproprié le journal de
position en exil Iran international a
révélé un scanner de son crâne mettant
en évidence une fracture osseuse une
hémorragie et une œdème cérébrale
compatible avec un passage à tabac
se rappelle de cette tragédie est
fondamentale pour prendre la mesure de
la mécanique infernale d'oppression
instaurer dans ce pays
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc où nous en sommes lorsque
l'on parle d'atteinte droit des femmes
et aux droits de l'homme en Iran
aujourd'hui un état totalitaire et
répressif
selon plusieurs organisations non
gouvernementales les femmes les
personnes LGBT et les membres de
minorités pardon ethnique ou religieuses
font face à des violences et à une
discrimination quotidienne dans toutes
les sphères de la société
avec naturellement l'approbation et
l'encouragement des autorités politiques
et religieuses dans les relations sont
particulièrement poreuses
les observateurs constatent également
des atteintes droits et à la liberté
d'expression d'associations et de
réunions l'interdiction de parti
politique indépendants de syndicats et
d'organisation de la société civile la
censure des médias sont mon écrans
du côté du système judiciaire l'égalité
devant la loi la séparation des
fonctions le secret de l'instruction les
droits de la défense la présomption
d'innocence la possibilité de voie de
recours et le principe du contradictoire
ils sont totalement piétinés aussi la
peine de mort y est pratiquée impunément
à l'issue de procès grotesque
face à ces données et au contexte de
mobilisation citoyenne évoquée au début
de mon intervention nous ne pouvons
qu’éprouver une certaine stupeur au
regard des informations qui nous
parviennent au compte-goutte en effet
bien que l'accès aux réseaux sociaux
soit devenu presque impossible en Iran
depuis le début de la contestation des
images et des vidéos édifiantes
parviennent à franchir la censure et
souligne le danger auquel les
manifestants s'opposent en descendant
dans la rue
mais au-delà du caractère émotionnel que
cela provoque à juste titre notre pays
se doit d'être à la manœuvre pour
promouvoir les valeurs que nous portons
fièrement dans notre devise républicaine
le premier réflexe doit être un message
d'unité et de solidarité dans le combat
pour les droits des femmes à disposer de
leur corps à arborer leurs chevelure à
interrompre une grossesse non désirée à
circuler librement à accéder au marché
du travail et bien d'autres il s'agit de
combat universel des femmes contre un
patriarcat qui tue mutile et Blaise
psychologiquement le deuxième réflexe
doit s'inscrire dans une stratégie
diplomatique coordonnée au niveau
européen et international pour apporter
un soutien plus concret aux populations
en danger
pour ce faire nous devons manipuler avec
une très grande précaution des mesures
restrictives car elles peuvent produire
l'effet pervers d'appauvrir les plus
fragiles
à titre d'exemple l'accord d'une
protection ici ou d'un autre pays
européenne nous semble être cohérent
avec les risques avérés de persécution
cette protection doit s'exécuter jusqu'à
ce qu'il y ait une mise en conformité du
doigt interne iranien avec le droit
international
en outre la saisie du conseil des droits
de l'homme et des Nations Unies paraît
adéquates pour ouvrir une enquête
indépendante sur place afin de
recueillir des preuves des agissements
du régime à l'encontre de son peuple et
d'engager des poursuites en temps utiles
ce recueil de preuves d'exaction peut
aussi être facilité via une stratégie
d'offensive numérique en accompagnant
les initiatives permettant à la
population de retrouver un accès normal
à Internet et de communiquer avec le
reste du monde
pour conclure simplement mon propos je
dirais que quel que soit les mesures
engagées par notre pays la France leur
finalité doit être l'humaine d'abord et
femme vie liberté
merci Madame
[Applaudissements]
la parole est ensuite madame
est également
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le 16 septembre pour
avoir mal porté son voile dans les rues
de Téhéran une jeune femme Massa à mini
est morte aux mains de la police des
mœurs pour avoir mal porté son voile la
futilité confondante des raisons qui ont
mené à son décès ne le rend que plus
révoltant plus avilissant pour ceux qui
s'en sont rendus coupables ce drame
vient rappeler au monde s'il en était
besoin la réalité de ces millions
d'iraniennes qui vivent sous le joug de
la Révolution islamique il expose aux
yeux de tous la brutalité des sbires de
ce régime anachronie qui considère
littéralement au travers de la DIA que
la vie d'une femme ne vaut que la moitié
de celle d'un homme mais il souligne
également le profond mépris des Molas
pour les minorités du pays dont les
cultures non depuis longtemps plus droit
de citer en Iran car Massa mini en plus
être une femme avait un autre tort celui
d'être kurde sa mort aura été
l'étincelle qui a fait s'embraser la
contestation qui Couvet d'abord dans sa
région natale du Kurdistan puis presque
immédiatement à Téhéran à Michel 2e
ville du pays et comme une traînée de
poudre dans tout l'Iran la mobilisation
n'a cessé depuis cette révolution des
femmes comme certains n'hésitent pas la
nommer engendre des scènes que nous
aurions tous crus impensable il y a
encore quelques semaines des iraniennes
qui descendent en masse dans la rue
détenu sous les acclamations de la foule
des iraniennes qui se coupent les
cheveux qui brûlent ce voile qui a coûté
la vie à l'une des leurs et qui lustre
plus que tout autre symbole le statut
d'infériorité dans lequel a voulu les
enfermer un islam rigoriste et
théocratique des femmes iraniennes qui
sont il est fondamental de le souligner
aujourd'hui soutenu et accompagner par
les hommes iraniens le rappel qui
s'exprime au cri de femmes vie liberté
et plus qu'un cri de colère
c'est bien sûr mais c'est aussi un
projet car ce sont des valeurs ces
valeurs qu'elles incarnent là-bas avec
un courage étourdissant et que nous
défendons ici parfois bien timidement
face au coup de boutoir qu'elle ne cesse
de subir ces dernières années alors
qu'elle peut être l'issue de ce
mouvement nous nous rappelons les
grandes manifestations de 2017 puis de
2019 qui déjà avait violemment remis en
cause le pouvoir en place il y a dans
les émeutes d'aujourd'hui qui sont à la
fois d'une ampleur plus importante et
d'une nature plus profonde le facilement
d'un régime contesté dans son essence et
les prémices de son effondrement une
certitude c'est née à moins rapidement
imposée la réponse des autorités sera
féroce et ne fera pour reprendre les
mots du chef du système judiciaire
iranien preuve d'aucune indulgence elle
s'est déjà traduite par des milliers
d'arrestations des dizaines de morts et
des centaines de blessés
et pour ajouter à l'intolérable elle
menace désormais la stabilité régionale
en projetant la violence au-delà du
territoire iranien Téhéran ainsi pris
prétexte de la crise pour frapper à coup
d'artillerie de drone et de missiles
balistique les locaux des parties
d'opposition Kurdes réfugiés de l'autre
côté de la frontière irakienne et
accusée de souffler sur les braises de
la contestation contre le régime le
gouvernement iranien vient en outre de
l'ancien avertissement sans équivoque à
ce qui dans les médias ont pris fêté
cause pour le mouvement qu'il s'agisse
de journalistes d'acteurs de musiciens
ou de sportifs on pense notamment à ses
joueurs de l'équipe nationale de
football qui avait assez née
publiquement cette phrase lourde de sens
les cheveux de nos filles sont
recouverts dans l'un seul
c'est très pression est avant tout une
meurtrissure faite au peuple iranien
mais elle est aussi une nouvelle insulte
aux valeurs de liberté de dignité que
nous avons en partage avec les
manifestants et les manifestants d'Iran
nous ne pouvons donc rester sans
réaction et nous tenir à l'écart de ce
qui est plus qu'un simple soubresaut de
l'histoire même si nos moyens d'action
il faut bien le reconnaître sont très
limitées il est probable que l'Union
européenne adopte des sanctions comme
elle le fait régulièrement chaque
nouvelle violation grave des droits de
l'homme en Iran malgré leur absence
prévisible d'effets concrets il est
indispensable que de telles mesures
soient prises car nous ne pouvons plus
nous contenter des nécessaires
condamnations de principes émis jusqu'à
présent la France madame la ministre
devra jouer un rôle majeur dans ce
processus européen mais aussi dans la
mobilisation internationale en ouvrant à
ce que toutes compétente des Nations
Unies se saisissent d'urgence de la
situation iranienne cela ne suffira sans
doute pas à infléchir le cours des
événements et encore moins la nature
profonde du régime iranien mais il est
essentiel que ce dernier mit sous
pression à l'intérieur le souhait
également à l'extérieur il est surtout
fondamental que les Iraniennes puissent
sentir qu'elles ne sont pas seules
qu'elles sachent que le monde les
regarde et qu'il est à leur côté il faut
en d'autres termes faire notre le
précept du philosophe Ali chariotti cité
par le prix Nobel iranien de la paix
Chirine et Badi dans son ouvrage La cage
dorée si vous ne pouvez éliminer
l'injustice au moins raconter là à tous
je vous remercie
merci cher collègue
la parole est à présent au président
Claude malurey
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le temps des
dictateurs est revenu
les démocraties au terme d'une lutte
implacable avait vaincu au 20e siècle
les deux totalitarismes aux dizaines de
millions de morts certains les croyaient
disparus à jamais sous nos yeux
l'international des tyrans se reforment
le boucher de Moscou le génocidaire des
Ouigours en Chine le Docteur Folamour de
Corée du Nord le massacreur de femmes de
Téhéran quelques autres se sont
regroupés leur seul but se venger
abattre l'Occident mettra bas la liberté
et d'abord celle des femmes
le pire est que comme au siècle
précédent ils ont des alliés dans nos
propres pays les adorateurs de Poutine
indifférent au massacre des Ukrainiens
les complices de tchi qui se moquent des
Ouigours et de Taïwan les alliés de
ramené expliquant au moment où les
Iraniennes meurent que le voile essayant
en un mot les populistes de tout bord
qui partagent une idée fixe avec les
despote la haine de la démocratie
depuis le début de la révolte en Iran et
jusqu'à la manifestation de dimanche
dernier à Paris ces professionnels de
l'indignation ceux qui battent le pavé
chaque semaine pour crier que la police
tue ou dénoncer le racisme systémique en
France avait disparu où était-il lors
des deux premières rassemblements en
soutien des femmes iraniennes en
week-end sans doute comme lors des
manifestations pour l'Ukraine leur
compte Twitter qui dénonce chaque jour
le patriarcat et l'islamophobie sont
devenus muets pas un mot de soutien pas
un appel contre la monarchie et sa
police des mœurs pendant qu'à Téhéran
les femmes meurent sous les coups et les
balles ils préfèrent dénoncer le
virilisme du barbecue faire l'éloge d'un
gifleur ou juger les harceleurs dans des
comités de transparence qui sont
l'oxymore le plus gros test inventé
depuis la dictature du prolétariat
quelques-uns d'entre eux ont réapparu
dimanche dernier lors du rassemblement
place de la République à Paris les
Iraniens et les Iraniennes
présents leur ont donné une grande leçon
de laïcité en signifiant à Madame
Rousseau qu'elle n'était pas la
bienvenue ils ont rendu claire pour tout
le monde c'est évident on ne peut en
même temps être pour le voile à Paris et
défendre celle qui brûle leur voile la
terre errant en sifflant madame Manon
Aubry
[Applaudissements]
en sifflant madame Manon Aubry ils ont
signifié qu'un parti ne peut en 2019
marcher avec les islamistes et en 2022
soutenir les victimes de la république
islamiste en un mot ils nous ont montré
qu'on ne peut être à la fois
communautariste et universaliste il faut
choisir en Iran des femmes risquent leur
vie pour se débarrasser du voile ici les
intersectionnelles se présentent le
présente comme une liberté écoutons ce
que leur réponse Chantal de rudeur le
voile n'est pas un objet culturel mais
un objet politique c'est le produit
phare de l'islamisme et c'est désormais
une affirmation antioxydante et
antidémocratique fin de citation ce
morceau d'étoffe Bourguiba l'appelait
l'épouvantable chiffon au naïf qui croit
que se voiler est un choix au
décoloniaux qui n'ont jamais lu un livre
l'histoire il faut rappeler que la lutte
contre le voile n'est pas une oppression
néocoloniale mais que les grands
dirigeants musulmans qui avaient compris
que la soumission de la femme
qui a été l'une des causes principales
du déclin de leur pays l'ont tous
combattu Atatürk le premier qu'il a
interdit dans les années 20 en Turquie
reste achats dans les années 30 en Iran
Bourguiba plus tard en Tunisie Nasser en
Égypte sans moquer publiquement devant
le grand muchtide à Lazare ce combat
qu'ils avaient gagné a été perdu depuis
la révolution islamique de 1979 les
femmes iraniennes reprennent aujourd'hui
ce flambeau contre les mollats les
ayatollahs les dictateurs les talibans
et leur police des mœurs c'est un coup
de poignard dans le dos de ses
combattantes qu'enfonce certaines
néo-féministes en condamnant toute
critique du voile au prétexte de ne pas
nourrir l'islamophobie un coup de
poignard dans le dos lorsque Sandrine
Rousseau déclare que le voile peut être
un embellissement
ou que rocailla Diallo aux affirmés que
la liberté peut être aussi dans le hijam
combien faudra-t-il de morts à Téhéran
pour que l'héroïsme des iraniennes les
forces à ouvrir les yeux et les oreilles
pour qu'elles cesse de danser le
Moonwalk de Michael Jackson en faisant
semblant de faire avancer la cause des
femmes tout en la faisant reculer le 21e
siècle s'annonce aussi dangereux que le
précédent il est temps de s'en rendre
compte ce qui croit que nous ne sommes
pas en guerre ou qui pour se rassurer se
forcent à le croire font une erreur
tragique car les dictateurs et les
ayatollahs eux savent qu'ils sont en
guerre contre nous puissent les
admirables iraniennes les héroïques
soldats ukrainiens et les courageux
dissident chinois nous convaincre de
nous rallier à leur cri liberté je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues et la parole est à
maintenant à Madame Mélanie Vogel
[Applaudissements]
je vais me permettre de commencer par
quelques mots qui ne sont pas de moi
pour danser dans la rue pour toutes les
fois où nous avons peur de nous
embrasser pour ne plus avoir honte
d'être pauvre pour l'enfant qui jusque
dans ses rêves doit fouiller dans les
poubelles pour respirer un air pur pour
les arbres qui meurent pour ces larmes
qui ne cessent de couler pour les
étudiants pour leur avenir pour les
enfants afghans pour cette petite fille
qui rêve d'être un garçon pour femme vie
liberté ces paroles se sont celles d'une
chanson de gerbinet pour emprisonné
quand il a publié une chanson qui n'a
pas composé qui n'a pas composé
puisqu'elle est formée à partir de
tweets postés courageusement par celles
et ceux qui se dressent en Iran contre
l'oppression elle démontre une chose une
chose qui est insupportable pour le
pouvoir en place ce qu'il se passe en
Iran aujourd'hui et profondément
différent de ce qui a pu se passer lors
des dernières révoltes parce que
précisément
ce n'est pas une révolte on a déjà vu
dans le passé une partie de la société
iranienne plutôt la jeunesse des villes
courageuses engagée réprimer se
mobiliser nous avons aujourd'hui à faire
à quelque chose d'une toute autre
dimension
on a là un mouvement de masse guidé par
des femmes qui est en train d'agréger
tout ce que la société iranienne compte
de personnes qui veulent être libre et
vivre dignement les femmes oui les
femmes d'abord puis les hommes aussi les
minorités ethniques politiques
religieuses sexuelle de genre les jeunes
qui ne voient pas d'avenir les pauvres
qui ne peuvent pas survivre dans un pays
où l'inflation et de plus de 40% les
universitaires qui ne peuvent pas
enseigner les paysans qui ne peuvent pas
cultiver leurs champs à cause de la
gestion désastreuse de l'eau toutes
celles et ceux qui au fond veulent
simplement respirer vivre aimer le
féminisme la lutte féministe déploie en
ce moment même en Iran et je pèse mes
mots sa puissance révolutionnaire ce qui
est en train de se passer en Iran n'est
pas une révolte c'est une révolution une
révolution pour la démocratie pour la
justice contre la tyrannie religieuse
une révolution pour les femmes pour la
vie et pour la liberté et une révolution
ça ne se calme pas ça ne se passe pas
une révolution une révolution ça se fait
ce sont donc les femmes qui entraîneront
un jour ou l'autre je ne sais pas quand
la chute de ce régime ce sont les femmes
qui ont lu ton pour leurs droits pour
leur liberté trace en ce moment même le
chemin des droits et des libertés tout
court ce sont les femmes qui ont
réclamant l'égalité pour elle peuvent
conquérir l'égalité tout court ce sont
les femmes aujourd'hui on entend souvent
en France et ailleurs dans le monde que
les féministes mènent des combats
marginaux
que les luttes des femmes sont
secondaires qu'il y a mieux à faire et
plusieurs gens que la vraie et la grande
la sérieuse politique c'est autre chose
les Iraniennes qui au prix et au risque
de leur vie brûlent leur foulards dans
la rue danse dans la rue hurle à la fin
de la dictature les Iraniennes font en
ce moment même la démonstration
puissante bouleversante et irréfutable
que dans notre monde ce sont les combats
des femmes qui sont l'avant-garde des
combats pour toutes et tous les valeurs
pour lesquelles se battent les
Iraniennes et les Iraniens réprimés dans
le sang ne sont pas des valeurs
occidentales importées des États-Unis ou
d'Israël ce sont des valeurs bien
ancrées en Iran ce sont leurs valeurs et
nous les partageons aussi face à cette
révolution face à cette répression dans
le sang face à ses morts pour la liberté
nous devons bien sûr
relayer leur voix bien sûr mais nous
devons aussi agir
Vladimir Poutine a envahi l'Ukraine le
24 février le soir même les dirigeants
européens se réunissaient et
s'accordaient sur un premier train de
sanction après l'invasion entrant en
vigueur dès le lendemain le 25 février
nous sommes au 19 juin de cette
révolution cela fait 19 jours qu'un
régime est en train de massacrer son
peuple et aujourd'hui
pas grand chose les négociations sur le
nucléaire iranien continue comme si de
rien n'était il n'y a pas au niveau
européen de nouvelles sanctions on
entend qu'on pourrait être en train d'en
préparer pour la prochaine réunion du
Conseil des ministres des Affaires
étrangères le 17 octobre le 17 octobre
c'est un mois après ce n'est pas
possible il faut agir et comme cet
après-midi nous ne pouvons que débattre
entre nous parler je vous propose de
faire au moins une chose que nous
pouvons faire ici au Parlement français
sans rien craindre
écoutez faire écouter quelques instants
cette hymne révolutionnaire qu'en Iran
on n'a pas le droit d'entendre librement
[Musique]
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues le 16 septembre dernier
une jeune femme de 22 ans est morte
alors qu'elle était aux mains de la
police des mœurs iraniennes pour port de
vêtements inappropriés
depuis cette date les femmes et la
jeunesse iranienne se soulèvent
massivement dans la rue et dans les
universités pour crier une révolte
légitime en réponse l'appareil
sécuritaire iranien réprime ces
manifestations avec brutalité si nous
sommes toutes et tous réunis aujourd'hui
dans cette hémicycle c'est parce que
cette arrestation la mort de Massa Amini
et la répression de ces manifestations
nous choquent profondément et que nous
les déplorons alors d'aucun pourrait
penser que débattre de la teinte au
droit des femmes et aux droits de
l'homme à 5000 km de Téhéran comme nous
le faisons aujourd'hui est inutile et
vain je pense tout le contraire car
c'est la liberté dont il est question
je veux croire que la liberté n'est
jamais acquise je veux croire que la
liberté ne se décrète pas mais qu'elle
s'exerce et qu'il est important que l'on
en débatte encore ici aujourd'hui si ce
débat nous permet de condamner la bord
de Massa mini et la répression violente
des manifestations qui s'en est suivie
il est surtout l'occasion de rappeler
que le combat pour la liberté que le
combat contre les violences faites aux
femmes et loin d'être gagné
aussi la France doit-elle utiliser toute
l'influence dont elle dispose pour
promouvoir l'universalisation de la
convention d'Istanbul au Conseil de
l'Europe qui représente aujourd'hui
l'instrument international le plus
abouti dans cette lutte indispensable
contre les violences faites aux femmes
sans doute faut-il aussi avec nos
partenaires européens envisager la
possibilité de recourir au régime de
sanctions de l'Union européenne en
matière de droits de l'homme
par ailleurs en tant que sénatrice des
Français de l'étranger comment ne pas
évoquer les quelques 1500 de nos
concitoyens qui vivent aujourd'hui en
Iran
parmi eux plus de 80% sont des
binationaux or vous le savez peut-être
mais l'Iran ne reconnaît pas la double
nationalité autrement dit ces
binationaux qui sont retenus ne peuvent
pas bénéficier de l'assistance
consulaire de la France le contexte
actuel fait que cette communauté
binationale qui est naturellement très
sensible à la question des droits de
l'homme et des droits des femmes et
particulièrement exposés
elle court le risque d'une arrestation
d'une détention arbitraire et d'un
jugement inéquitable
ces derniers jours la presse c'est
d'ailleurs fait l'écho de l'annonce du
ministère iranien des renseignements
affirmant que 9 ressortissants étrangers
auraient été arrêtés dont au moins un
français je veux ici relayer la vive
inquiétude de la Communauté française en
Iran et dire que la France doit tout
mettre en oeuvre pour protéger ses
ressortissants notre groupe condamne
fermement l'arrestation et la mort de
Massa Amini ainsi que la répression
violente des manifestations qui a lieu
aujourd'hui en Iran il soutient vivement
cette demande de liberté des femmes
iraniennes je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à présent à Madame Marie
avec Carlotti
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers et chers collègues le sang
coule en Iran et c'est d'abord le sang
des femmes la révolte que connaît l'Iran
depuis 3 semaines porte le nom de Massa
Amini morte le 16 septembre après avoir
été arrêté à Téhéran parce que son voile
couvrait mal ses cheveux elle avait 22
ans et son visage martyre est devenu le
symbole puissant de l'iniquité et de la
brutalité du régime iranien les images
qui nous parviennent nous sert la gorge
elle qui arrache leur voile pour le
jeter au feu elle qui coupe leurs
cheveux et qui brave la police des mœurs
et elle qui entonnent bella ciao ce
chant déjà émouvant en lui-même quand il
évoque le courage et l'esprit de
résistance devient complètement
bouleversant lorsqu'il est entonné par
les Iraniennes dont les sœurs descendent
dans la rue pour dénoncer
l'obscurantisme du régime au risque d'y
laisser leur propre vie en février 79
elle va même avant même l'instauration
de la République islamique d'Iran
l'ayatollack cromeni considérait déjà la
liberté de la femme comme le principal
obstacle à son projet politique en les
uniformisant par l'obligation d'abord du
port du voile puis par un manteau puis
par un code couleur on a voulu réprimer
leur identité les transformer en nombre
d'elles-mêmes les privés de leur statut
social et le reléguer au confins de la
vie publique et depuis l'élection de
l'ultra conservateur
Ibrahim raïti en juin 2021 depuis que
l'aile la plus dure a mis la main sur le
système la situation des femmes c'est
encore dégradée pendant toutes ces
années d'horrible crime ont été commis
contre les femmes le vitriol pour refus
de mariage la décapitation pour soupçon
de fleurs la lapidation pour délits
d'adultère la femme a été sacrifiée au
nom de l'honneur l'honneur de l'homme
l'honneur de la famille de la société de
l'État mais elles n'ont jamais baissé
les bras aujourd'hui elles sont aux
avant-postes du soulèvement car elle ne
supporte plus ce voile qui les entrave
et au fil des jours ça te révolte
féministe a pris une autre dimension
celle de la contestation du régime
théocratique le soulèvement a d'abord
touché les étudiants parce que ce sont
toujours eux qui sont les plus pros à
réagir puis il a gagné toutes les
catégories sociales toutes les villes
toutes les provinces et les
protestataires aujourd'hui descendent
dans la rue au nom de mort au dictateur
et en ce sens je crois moi aussi que le
mouvement est assez différent de ce qui
s'est passé en 2017 et 2019 désormais le
renversement du régime des molards et
réclamé et leur système corrompu
corrompu alors qu'il y a entre 50 et 80%
de la population selon les territoires
qui vient en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté les femmes sont au primées en
Iran mais pas seulement les femmes tout
le monde tout le monde les avocats sont
emprisonnés les manifestations
d'enseignants sont réprimés la liberté
d'associations entraver la liberté de la
presse n'existe pas le rapporteur
spécial de l'ONU a dénoncé la situation
des minorités il se dit à l'armée par le
nombre l'exécution arbitraire en
particulier envers les baloutes et les
Kurdes la République islamique qui a
pourtant hérité d'un empire pluriatnique
cet employé a réprimer toutes les
revendications régionales elle défend un
centralisme autoritaire réfractaire aux
minorités et elle développe comme contre
toute forme d'opposition la violence
d'État dans les prisons iraniennes on
côtoie toutes les composantes de la
société civile les militants politiques
les syndicalistes et les enseignants les
signets à acheter les journalistes vous
en avez parlé et depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de racisme c'est l'escalade
encore plus des arrestations arbitraires
la population est excédée par les
privations de toutes sortes et aspirent
à plus de liberté alors le régime c'est
que une nouvelle épreuve latente au tout
tard ça va être la succession du Guide
suprême cette octogénaire à la santé
chancelante qui trouve quand même
suffisamment d'énergie pour condamner la
communauté internationale et nous
accuser d'ingérence dans ce contexte ils
sont peu enclin à discuter la police
répond par la violence elle recourt
semble-t-il aux armes létales et à
chaque manifestation elle tue moi je ne
sais pas ce que va devenir ce mouvement
de réfol tels qui va porter la
révolution je ne sais pas à temps les
leaders des oppositions de toutes les
oppositions ont été emprisonné tués
poussés à l'exil mais ce que je sais
c'est que ces femmes font preuve d'un
incroyable courage et que l'on se doit
nous responsa politique d'être à la
hauteur nous n'avons nous avons été un
peu lâche pendant ces 43 ans
d'oppression la France et l'Union
européenne doivent parler plus fort
mesdames la ministre pour dénoncer cette
répression sanglante vous avez proposé
le gel des avoir et l'interdiction de
voyager où en est-on est-ce que ça va se
réaliser alors que le régime se sert des
négociations sur le nucléaire iranien
pour obtenir le silence de la communauté
internationale en tout cas moi ce que je
sais c'est que la France doit rester
dans son rôle c'est à dire la défense de
ceux qui se base pour la liberté je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci cher collègue de la parole est au
président Pierre Laurent pour 5 minutes
également
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues femmes vie liberté
depuis trois semaines c'est le cri de
colère et d'espoir qui retentit dans les
rues iraniennes ce cri de dignité
d'humanité je veux évidemment le saluer
avec émotion au nom de tout notre groupe
cet appel à la liberté nous devons le
soutenir de toutes nos forces le 16
septembre Macha Amini a été odieusement
assassiné par la brigade des mœurs cet
instrument d'oppression du régime des
mollats elle est devenue le symbole de
la révolte populaire son crime avoir mal
porté le foulard symbole de la
soumission imposée aux femmes par le
pouvoir théocratique à la tête de la
République islamique d'Iran depuis 1979
les femmes iraniennes n'ont cessé d'être
exposées au violon sexistes et
patriarcale aux violences d'un régime
politique et religieux obscurantiste qui
a fait de la domination des femmes un
instrument de la domination sur toute la
société
la situation s'est encore empirée depuis
l'arrivée aux affaires de l'ultra
hébrahim raïti en 2021 ainsi des médias
iraniens révélaient encore récemment
l'intention de recourir à l'intelligence
artificielle pour identifier les femmes
non ou mal volées les sévices et les
humiliations frappent toute la société
iranienne elle s'exerce contre les
femmes violemment et aussi contre de
larges fractions du peuple contre la
population kurde contre la jeunesse
contre toutes les forces du mouvement
ouvrier au profit exclusif des cercles
dirigeants du pouvoir et d'oligarchie
prédatrice qui les soutiennent
face aux femmes qui jettent avec courage
leur foulard qui les brûlent qui se
coupe les cheveux face à la jeunesse
femme et homme qui se joignent au
mouvement la répression et cette fois
encore féroce on dénombre des dizaines
de morts des milliers d'arrestations
arbitraire ce soulèvement des femmes
iraniennes est un signal de courage et
d'espoir pour les femmes du monde entier
ont lutte contre les oppressions
sexistes et patriarcales religieuse ou
non pour les femmes kurdes on lutte dans
tous les pays de la région notamment
dans la Turquie voisine pour les femmes
d'Afghanistan d'Arabie Saoudite des pays
du Golfe pour les femmes victimes du
viol utilisé comme une arme de guerre
sur toute la planète pour les femmes
victimes des réseaux mondiaux de
prostitutionnelles mi-anus par le
remarquable rapport du Sénat pour les
femmes du monde en lutte contre toutes
les violences sexistes et contre les
attaques qui s'amplifient contre le
droit à l'ivierger notamment en Europe
et aux États-Unis oui la lutte des
femmes en Iran qui prenante de ce
mouvement mondial pour libérer toute
l'humanité des dominations sexistes et
patriarcales elle a notre plein soutien
les femmes en Iran ne secouent plus
seulement leur voile elle secoue
aujourd'hui le régime politique
répressif d'une théocratie obscurantiste
qui étouffe la civilisation de ce grand
pays de 84 millions d'habitants depuis
10 ans des mouvements de contestation
des politiques sociales du régime ont
déjà secoué le pays en 2009-2017
2018/2019 aujourd'hui se joignent au
mouvement des femmes d'autres secteurs
de la société pour dénoncer la dictature
politique de ce régime le peuple iranien
ne veut plus de ce carcan dictatorial
l'Iran connaît de profondes mutations
urbanisées sécularisée son peuple la
cessé d'élever son niveau d'éducation en
particulier chez les femmes quand ces
structures politiques elles se sont
fossilisées
la paix du monde a besoin d'un Iran qui
retrouve la voix de la démocratie et de
la justice sociale un force est de
constater que la mise au banc de l'Iran
par les États-Unis avec le retrait
unilatéral en 2018 de la corde sur le
nucléaire iranien et les sanctions
américaines à nourris et non combattu la
radicalisation répressive du régime qui
se déchaîne aujourd'hui contre les
femmes tout le peuple iranien paye cher
une terrible crise économique auxquelles
s'ajoute le lourd tribu du covid-19 un
jeune sur quatre est au chômage la
moitié de la population a plongé dans la
pauvreté madame la ministre la
solidarité avec les femmes d'Iran
nous devons l'inscrire tout autant dans
la lutte mondiale pour l'émancipation
des femmes contre tous les obscures
antismes comme dans la lutte pour un
nouvel ordre mondial juste dans lequel
le peuple diront puisse trouver la voie
d'un développement démocratique juste
solidaire en paix avec ses voisins la
France doit agir clairement dans ce sens
comme le dit le proverbe iranien quand
la corde de l'injustice grossit outre
mesure elle se déchire puisse toutes ces
injustices se déchiraient et le plus tôt
sera le mieux
c'est pas évident
et la parole est au président Laurent
Lafont pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la mort de Massa
mini quelques jours après son
arrestation pour port de vêtements
inapproprié et l'élément déclencheur
d'un mouvement plus global de
contestation du régime en place
son nom est devenu un symbole de
ralliement pour tout le peuple iranien
désireux de vivre dans un état de droit
depuis la révolution de 1979 ces femmes
et ses hommes subissent les pressions
d'un pouvoir autoritaire et répressif
comme le rappeler ma collègue Annick
Billon et beaucoup d'entre vous
l'instauration de leur constitution les
a priver d'une grande partie de leurs
droits les plus absolues et fondamentaux
cette main mise des autorités sur leurs
droits et renforcée par le recours à la
censure l'accès aux médias et réseaux
sociaux y est très restreint cet été le
Parlement a précipité la préparation
d'une proposition de loi pour ériger en
infraction la production et la diffusion
d'outils permettant de contourner la
censure ainsi des milliers de personnes
ont été interrogés poursuivis ou détenus
et des centaines d'autres sont
emprisonnés simplement pour avoir
exprimé leur conviction par que des
journalistes des artistes des avocats ou
des enseignants comme la chercheuse
franco-iranienne fariba abdelka condamné
à 5 ans de prison pour atteindre à la
sécurité nationale ou aux chercheurs
suédaux iraniens à djalali condamné à
mort la violence est admise et
systématique et la peine de mort est
devenue un instrument de répression des
dissidents et minorités aujourd'hui les
contestations provoquées par la mort de
Massa Amini ne cesse de prendre de
l'ampleur les universités sont devenus
le théâtre de violents affrontements
enseignants et étudiants ils sont
particulièrement exposés des vidéos
témoignent de la violence des
répressions et arrestations alors que
les étudiants scandaient les étudiants
préfèrent la mort à l'humiliation
la répression est menée jusqu'au cœur de
la prestigieuse université Sharif
attéhéran selon des témoins incités par
le site d'information indépendants Iran
wire dimanche dernier des étudiants ont
été battus d'autres ont essuyé des tirs
lors de l'intrusion des forces de police
qui ont bouclé le bâtiment armé de
paintball de gaz lacrymogènes et de
fusil à pompe plusieurs jeunes se
réveillent
si une partie des étudiants alors pu
quitter l'université d'autres sont
restés bloqués à l'intérieur des témoins
attestent avoir vu des arrestations de
plusieurs dizaines d'étudiants et
professeurs des vidéos circulent
montrant des jeunes cagoule noir sur la
tête embarqués dans des fourgons de
police
étudiant et professeur de nombreux pays
ont exprimé à la suite de ces mouvements
un qualifiables leurs colères exigent la
libération de leurs camarades détenus
par la police notre inquiétude est
grande pour tous ceux et toutes celles
qui manifestent et se soulève
aujourd'hui en Iran l'ONG Human Rights
fait état d'un bilan particulièrement
lourd plus de 90 morts tandis que le
ministère des renseignements iraniens
revendique l'arrestation de 9
ressortissants de pays européens dont la
France pour le rôle dans les
manifestations
pardon iranienne est prix Nobel de la
pêche sherine et Badi a récemment
soutenu qu'il revient au pays
occidentaux de réduire leur contact avec
l'Iran parce qu'un pouvoir qui est sourd
aux demandes de son peuple doit être
boycoté d'un point de vue politique
c'est aussi le sens de notre demande
aujourd'hui dans une totale inédit des
différents groupes du Sénat
la parole est à Madame Valérie Boyer
pour cinq minutes
merci
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues depuis deux semaines
après la mort de la jeune Macha Amimi en
Iran des femmes courageux avec l'appui
de certains hommes pour suivre leur
évolution au péril de leur vie mais
alors que nous saluons un juste titre le
courage de ses iraniennes je profite de
ce temps de parole pour vous dire à quel
point je regrette que nous ne parlions
pas davantage des femmes arméniennes
actuellement torturé démembrés violets
tués et filmé par les azeries fiers de
leur forfait je pense en particulier à
anouche à pétillant et à toutes les
autres cette barbarie se fait dans
l'indifférence générale il ne peut y
avoir de hiérarchie de l'horreur le sang
des Arméniens coule comme celui des
Ukrainiens ou des Iraniens
ne les abandonnons pas pour autant alors
que la France d'Emmanuel Macron veut
servir d'exemples en matière de respect
de droits des femmes qu'en est-il nous
avons l'Union européenne et le Conseil
de l'Europe qui enchaîne des campagnes
de communication provoies sans
protestation de notre gouvernement que
ce soit avec le slogan la liberté dans
le hijab ou avec des affiches de petites
filles voilées doit-on y voir la marque
de la Turquie d'Erdogan toujours membre
du Conseil de l'Europe ou d'organisation
islamiste comme les Frères musulmans qui
tentent depuis des années d'imposer des
programmes de recherche d'agir sur nos
institutions comment accepter ce
détournement de fonds publics des
institutions démocratiques utilisées
pour normaliser n'ont pas une liberté
religieuse mais un enfermement dans le
sexe une négation de la personne un
interdit de liberté un interdit
d'égalité un interdit de fraternité
l'Europe s'y prompte à remettre en
question les valeurs ne peut être le
cheval de Troie de l'islam politique
pourtant vous pratiquez toujours la
politique du Mans en même temps vous
nous dites agir mais aucune sanction n'a
jamais été envisagée lutter contre
l'Union européenne ou le Conseil de
l'Europe ni à l'encontre d'associations
qui font en France la promotion du voile
ou même d'organismes publics qui pose
avec des femmes voilées aucune enquête
pour savoir d'où viennent ces promotions
indignes pire encore depuis que les
Iraniennes se révoltent nous entendons
de nouveau dans notre pays cette petite
musique liberté de ne pas porter le
voile liberté de pouvoir le porter alors
où les femmes iraniennes bravent
l’interdit certains dans notre pays
devraient méditer l'exemple de ces
militantes de la liberté comme si le
voile ne serait en France qu'un vêtement
ou un embellissement ou une liberté si
machin a mini a été tué ce n'est pas
pour un simple bout de tissu accepter
cette soi-disant Motte c'est conforter
le communautarisme dans notre pays c'est
choisir le camp des oppresseurs c'est
choisir le camp des islamistes c'est
abandonné les femmes d'Iran
d'Afghanistan d'Arabie qui sont obligés
de se voiler mais aussi celle d'Algérie
de Tunisie de Siri au d'ailleurs qui le
font au nom de la présence sociale comme
celle de nos quartiers
ne nous l'aurons pas la bataille du
voile et l'expression la plus visible de
la volonté des intégristes de marquer
leur territoire et de soumettre les
femmes comme les hommes cette forme de
purification vestimentaire en est le
marqueur aujourd'hui nous voyons dans
notre pays n'ont pas des zones de
non-droits mais des zones d'un autre
droit ou l'islamisme s'affiche en
uniforme et organise un véritable
contrôle social d'ailleurs pendant que
les Iraniennes héroïques arrachent leur
voile pour sentir le vent dans leurs
cheveux des adolescentes reviennent des
tenues islamistes dans nos écoles mais
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
préfère déplorer à l'étranger l'absence
de débat nuancé sur les questions
ethno-raciales et découvre ce que nous
dénonçons depuis des années l'école
n'est malheureusement plus le sanctuaire
de notre République mais devient le
théâtre de revendications communautaire
pire encore de menaces islamistes
comment ne pas penser à Samuel Paty
l'école construit l'islam détruit
l'islamisme détruit pour reprendre
Vincent tremolet De Villiers hier
c'était là qu'on faisait des Français
aujourd'hui c'est à l'école que la se
défait votre faiblesse et votre inaction
inquiète les Français mener la bataille
contre le voile islamique et mener la
bataille pour l'humanité pour la liberté
car en enlevant aux femmes leur identité
leur visage on leur enlève leur humanité
et pourtant vous êtes toujours opposé
aux propositions que nous avons
formulées je pense notamment aux
propositions nous avons fait dans la loi
séparative et vous nous avez même accusé
de déposer des amendements textiles quel
mépris je pense à l'interdiction du
voile des accompagnatrices scolaires
pour les mineurs ou encore le burkini il
est noté responsabilité de dire haut et
fort que nous ne pouvons accepter qu'en
France comme ailleurs qu'une petite
fille porte ce signe d'infériorisation
parce que c'est de ça dont il s'agit
nous le devons aux Français nous le
devons à nos jeunes filles nous le
devons à celle et ceux qui prennent le
risque de leur vie pour leur liberté
nous ne devons aussi à celles et ceux
qui se réfugient en France pour cette
liberté nous le devons à toutes ces
femmes à travers le monde qui risque
leur vie avec courage pour refusé de
porter le voile
femme vie liberté un beau slogan en
France comme ailleurs car pour reprendre
ce que disait Périclès il n'est point de
bonheur sans liberté ni de liberté son
courage alors aujourd'hui ayant du
courage et de la cohérence c'est-à-dire
refusons bien évidemment et soutenant
les femmes les femmes iraniennes mais
refusant aussi ces marques
d'infériorisation dans notre pays
la parole est maintenant la présidente
Laurence Rossignol
pour 5000 pour 4 minutes pardon
voilà 43 ans que les Iraniennes et les
Iraniens qui avaient fait tomber la
dictature du chat vivent sous une autre
dictature 43 ans que les molas ont
confisqué les révoltes populaires et les
aspirations démocratiques de 78 et 79
43 ans que nous accueillons nos amis
féministes démocrates syndicalistes
kurde homosexuel 43 ans que nous lisons
leurs livres que nous voyons leur film
et que nous faisons ce que nous pouvons
pour qu'on ne s'habitue pas à la
répression au pendaison au décapitations
et aux persécutions
43 ans que la République islamique
d'Iran impose à son pays et au monde sa
haine des femmes et sa haine des Juifs
alors aujourd'hui nous pleurons
d'émotion
nous tremblons de peur chaque matin nous
regardons les vidéos que au péril de
leur vie
désiraniennes et des Iraniens ont capté
pendant les manifestations dans les
universités dans les collèges dans les
rues
c'est une révolution féministe qui a
émergé aujourd'hui en Iran une
révolution féministe qui entraîne une
insurrection générationnelle et qui
mobilise le soutien d'une grande partie
de la population
les femmes qui sont l'obsession des
islamistes partout
sont aussi leur première menace parce
que leur combat est universel parce que
ce sont elles qui sont le ferment de la
rébellion parce que en fait les
Iraniennes s'y trompent pas
c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave du tout les Iraniens de
citrons pas personne n'est libre dans un
pays où les femmes ne le sont pas
alors beaucoup de nos collègues avant
moi ont eu des mots très beaux très
forts pour dire leur solidarité avec le
port iranien pour dire
leur crainte du lendemain leur crainte
de ces jeunes devoirs ces jeunes gens
que l'on connaît par j'évoquais tout à
l'heure les vidéos et un jour on les
voit et le lendemain on apprend qu'ils
ont disparu que leur corps a été rendu à
leur famille tout le monde tremble du
moment où la répression sauvage peut
s'abattre sur eux
mais je voudrais en toute courtoisie
dire
certains de nos collègues et je peux me
permettre de le dire parce que personne
ne m'a jamais prise en défaut lorsqu'il
s'agit de caractériser le voile
islamique la Baïa le hijab tous ces
oraux pour ceux qui sont des outils
politiques
d'un projet religieux et politique qui
tous portent
l'oppression et la domination des femmes
en eux que nous ne devons pas poursuivre
nos discussions franco-françaises voire
même franco-européennes aujourd'hui en
saisissant le prétexte la révolte en
Iran nous aurons l'occasion d'en
débattre encore ne vous inquiétez pas
et puis je voudrais dire aussi que
Pierre Laurent d'autres ont cité les
femmes d'Afghanistan les femmes
d'Arménie cité par Valérie Boyer tout à
l'heure
en fait les femmes à peu près partout
dans cette planète à peu près partout
pour dire aussi que les fous de Dieu ne
sont pas tous islamistes il y a aussi
des fous de Dieu dans bien d'autres pays
qui ne sont pas des pays islamistes les
fous de Dieu sont à la Cour suprême aux
États-Unis à privé les femmes de leurs
droits d'avorter les fous de Dieu sont
dans les favels à Rio a drainé les voies
des classes populaires en faveur
d'addictateurs d'un fasciste pardon je
me suis trompé ce n'est pas un dictateur
d'un fasciste bolsonar qui menace non
seulement son peuple et la planète alors
combattre des fous de Dieu c'est notre
responsabilité partout sans choisir les
dieux
[Applaudissements]
et la parole maintenant revient à
Monsieur Hugues saurai pardon pour 4
minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
Malala avec 15 ans lorsque des talibans
lui ont tiré une balle dans la tête
alors qu'elles se rendait à l'école
Amina Ali avait 17 ans lorsque des
mercenaires de Boko Haram l'ont enlevé
avec 219 autres jeunes filles alors
qu'elle était au lycée
Marza Amini arrêté par la police des
mœurs avait 22 ans lorsqu'elle est morte
dans les jolies iraniennes alors qu'elle
avait laissé s'échapper quelques mèches
de cheveux de son voile tout avait en
commun de vouloir vivre libre dans des
états où le pouvoir religieux militaire
ou politique le leur interdisait parce
qu'elles étaient des femmes
la mort de Marsa Amini nous bouleverse
comme elle a bouleversé son pays elle a
suscité une vague de courage admirable
chez les femmes et des hommes que tout
menace à ce jour plus de 60 personnes
ont donné leur vie après que Marsa ait
perdu la sienne et ils sont des milliers
à la risquée dans les rues d'Iran au nom
de la plus haute idée qu'ils se font de
la dignité humaine
dans notre pays où les allégories de la
liberté prennent si souvent les traits
de femmes le cri des iraniennes résonne
avec un éco-partier en Occident nous
savons combien le chemin vers cette
liberté ardue lent et exigeant jamais
garanti bien qu'il habite notre
philosophie depuis des siècles nous
savons également ce que la lutte pour
les droits des femmes supposent de cette
même exigence
si l'autonollerait cette promesse faite
au monde cette assurance qu'il se battra
toujours pour que chacun quel qu'il soit
puisse vivre sans crainte pour son
existence et que jamais une femme ne
meurt du simple fait d'être femme alors
l'Occident se doit profondément d'être
cohérent face à un état qui a fait de
l'oppression des femmes un marqueur de
sa politique il en va de ce que nous
sommes l'histoire récente de l'Iran nous
montre que rien n'est acquis il nous
incombe devrait pour que de telles
menaces ne prennent jamais racine sur
notre territoire la radicalité qu'elle
soit religieuse ou politique n'a sa
place ni dans les principes qui nous
font ni dans les traités qui nous
régissent ni dans les lois que nous
élaborons nous devons aux femmes
iraniennes de ne pas laisser se répandre
chez nous ce qu'elles veulent tant voir
disparaître chez elle
madame la ministre le radicalisme
politique et religieux qui s'attaque aux
droits de l'homme en Iran s'embarrasse
peu des frontières nous sommes nous
savons bien qu'il pèse aussi à moindre
degré en Europe et dans notre pays on ne
peut indéfiniment chérir les causes dont
on déplore les conséquences le temps mis
pour expulser Hasan l'augmentation du
nombre de signalements d'atteintes à la
laïcité à l'école que le ministre
papendial confirmait la semaine dernière
ou encore la campagne de communication
du Conseil de l'Europe la liberté dont
le hijab ne sont que quelques exemples
d'un entrisme inquiétant opéré parfois
avec le concours passif de l'État madame
la ministre cet événement tragique
interroge notre cohérence la
condamnation inanimes que nous portons
contre cet acte ne suffit pas il revient
à votre gouvernement de défendre les
principes qui nous font et qui nous
portent
vous engagez-vous à propager les voix la
voix des iraniennes les valeurs de
liberté et d'égalité dans les instances
nationales européennes et
internationales en luttant notamment
pour que les principes radicaux qui
régissent aujourd'hui des systèmes
étatiques oppressifs comme l'Iran
tendent vous engagez-vous partout où
notre pays s'investit à œuvrer pour
qu'aucune forme de soutien ni économique
ni moral ni politique ne soit offert aux
partisans de telles idéologies vous
engagez-vous à envoyer un signal clair
un Malala yousafai aminali à Marsa à
mini celui que jamais nous ne tendrons
la main de quelques façons que ce soit à
ce qui a voulu les détruire le courage
des Iraniens et des iraniennes appellent
aujourd'hui le nôtre je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Madame Catherine Colonna
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs merci de ce
débat et merci de vos interventions très
largement convergentes entre elles et
convergentes aussi avec nos propres
lignes même si chacun s'exprimera à sa
façon
vous l'avez tous dit le 16 septembre
dernier Massa amélie est morte à 22 ans
sous les coups de la police des mœurs
de la République islamique d'Iran il
avait arrêté au prétexte qu'elle aurait
mal porté son voile
[Musique]
une vie détruite et pourquoi pour une
mèche de cheveux dépassant d'un voile
quelques jours plus tard une autre jeune
fille puis tant d'autres étaient
victimes de la même violence lorsque la
répression du régime s'abattit
brutalement sur les manifestantes et les
manifestants partout en Iran de sa
caisse la ville natale de Massey Amini
elle avait une sainte de com de machad
athées
tant de vie détruite parce que ces
jeunes femmes osées revendiquer leur
liberté parce qu'elles osaient affirmer
que leur dignité ne valait pas moins
mais autant que celle d'un homme
c'est aujourd'hui un même cri qui
retentit femme vie liberté c'est ce cri
que le régime cherche à étouffer par la
censure et par la violence à ce jour les
ONG ont fait état de plus de 100
victimes sans doute le chiffre est-il
supérieur et de plus de 1000
arrestations de militantes et de
militants d'avocats et d'avocats de
journalistes de citoyens de femmes et
d'hommes unis par la même volonté
d'émancipation
femme vit liberté c'est ce cri aussi que
la diaspora iranienne Antonne en Déco de
Paris à San Francisco de Londres à Rome
ou à Erbil
dès le 19 septembre la France a condamné
avec la plus grande fermeté les
violences et entraîné la mort de machin
et Minnie et la violence utilisée contre
les manifestants
comme je l'ai rappelé hier à l'Assemblée
nationale nous avons appelé les
autorités iraniennes à respecter le
droit de manifester pacifiquement
respecter le droit au rassemblement et
aussi à respecter l'exercice de leur
métier par les journalistes nous l'avons
fait officiellement et j'ai fait
moi-même auprès de la presse aussitôt en
marche de l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies où ici en France à
plusieurs reprises
les autorités iraniennes ont considéré
qu'il s'agissait d'une forme d'ingérence
que de rappeler les principes
fondamentaux des droits de l'homme elles
ont cru bon de le faire savoir à notre
ambassade sur place j'ai donc décidé de
faire convoquer le chargé d'affaires de
l'ambassade d'Iran à Paris car il n'y a
pas en ce moment d'ambassadeurs d'Iran
il a été reçu vendredi dernier au Quai
d'Orsay il lui a été dit clairement ce
que nous pensons des méthodes iraniennes
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ceux
qui se jouent dans les rues Téhéran et
dans les autres villes iraniennes c'est
la liberté il y a d'un côté la
répression une répression brutale que
nous condamnons dans les termes les plus
forts une répression menée contre des
femmes et des hommes qui manifestent
pour le respect de leurs droits et de
leur dignité une répression que nous
avons dénoncé à plusieurs reprises et
que tu continueront à dénoncer je peux
vous rassurer monsieur sénateur
évidemment sur ce point nous le faisons
au conseil de droits de l'Homme à Genève
nous le faisons dans toutes les ancêtres
internationales et nous le faisons dans
chacun de nos échanges bilatéraux quels
qu'on soit le niveau
rappelons aussi que l'Iran à lui-même
souscrit au principe fondamentaux que
nous défendons ici les principes du
pacte relatif aux droits civils et
politiques des Nations Unies auxquelles
elle a adhéré en 1975 et je précise en
réponse à madame la sénatrice billon que
l'Iran en effet été élu la Commission
des Nations Unies sur les conditions de
la femme c'est la règle majoritaire aura
au sein de chaque groupe géographique
auquel nous n'appartenons pas au
demeurant cette organisation est utile
car il produit des documents de
référence sur la situation des droits
des femmes dans les pays et permet donc
de mieux savoir ce qui se passe chez eux
enfin ces autorités il y a une
aspiration à la liberté et je dis en
face face aux auteurs de la répression
mais je devrais dire partout car cette
aspiration est la liberté nous la voyons
partout s'exprimer les femmes diront
veulent vivre libre et un grand nombre
d'iranien les suivent désormais des
villages Kurdes d'Iran au métropole du
Baluchistan de la Caspienne au golf les
femmes diront veulent vivre les femmes
diront volent leurs droits soient
garantis les femmes diront aspirent à ce
que leur régal dignité soit respectée
le courage des femmes iraniennes force
d'admiration et nous oblige nous
soutenons leurs aspirations et nous
continuerons à les soutenir mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
nous sommes en première ligne pour agir
avec notre partenaire européens notre
réponse doit être à la hauteur de
l'enjeu et en ce sens nous avons lancé
dès la semaine dernière avec nos
partenaires européens des travaux afin
de sanctionner les auteurs de la
répression il s'agira de geler les avoir
et de geler d'interdire donc le droit de
voyager aux individus identifiés comme
responsables des violences il nous
espérons madame la sénatrice Carlotti
que ce soit fait d'ici 8 à 10 jours nous
sommes 27 dois-je vous le rappeler
madame la sénatrice Vogel permettez-moi
aussi de préciser que les négociations
sur le retour aux jpcoe ce sont conclus
par la présentation d'un texte que
l'Iran n'a pas pour leur accepté en
d'autres termes elle ne se déroule donc
pas quoi que la conclusion d'un accord
aurait un fort intérêt pour empêcher
l'Iran d'accéder aux seuil nucléaire ce
qui sera de loin préférable chacun en
conviendra
aucune société nous le savons ne peut se
développer sereinement si elle n'assure
pas l'égalité des droits l'égalité entre
femmes et hommes l'égalité entre femmes
et hommes qui ont une condition du
développement et qui est même le gage
d'une société libre un élément
fondamental de la justice indispensable
à nos vies
ce combat essentiel n'est donc pas notre
seul combat parce qu'une société injuste
avec les femmes et tout simplement une
société injuste pour tous nous
continuerons à dénoncer les arrestations
arbitraires des cinéastes des militants
des droits de l'Homme les femmes et des
hommes engagés pour la défense de la
liberté d'expression d'étudiants de
journalistes nous continuerons à
dénoncer les exécutions auxquelles il
est procédé y compris les exécutions de
mineurs
et nous le faisons et nous le ferons
parce que c'est notre responsabilité
nous le faisons et nous le ferons parce
que nous avons le droit moral et
politique de défendre les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres oui mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs nous
disons tous ensemble la femme et l'égale
de l'homme en Iran comme ailleurs je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]